foreign
this morning we're sharing a story of
extraordinary heroism that emerged from
the massive storm that recently slammed
Buffalo New York a woman noticed a man
was struggling in the blizzard outside
her window so she brought the stranger
to safety inside but that was just the
start of the care that she gave him lead
National correspondent David begno went
to Buffalo to meet the woman and learned
how her life-saving acts of kindness
created lasting connections
right here
this is the first time that Yvonne white
is going to see the home where her
brother was treated like family
by a woman who rescued him put it in
perspective you saved his life you saved
another human being's life
during the blizzard last month in
Buffalo New York Shakira Autry took
action when others might be less willing
what you did was just beautiful just
beautiful I just did yeah but you know
he made him comfortable he felt the love
he was at my door banging when I woke up
I heard help help it was Christmas Eve
Shakira looked out her window and saw
that man struggling in the snow he keeps
screaming I don't know what to do I feel
so terrible it was four degrees outside
I can't even walk like the wind is so
bad the wind was gusting 53 miles per
hour he had no gloves on looked lost and
in pain
the 35 year old and her boyfriend Trent
alls Jr took him in
64 year old Joey white has the mental
capacity of a 10 year old according to
his sister
he lives in a group home just a few
blocks away from Shakira's home that
morning Joey left home headed for a
movie theater where he's worked as a
custodian for 40 years
is unclear how long he lingered in the
cold he was so Frozen his clothing was
completely froze what were his fingers
like they were it was bobbed up with the
bag in his hand I told him I walked him
through I said I have to cut the bag
because the bag was froze he had ice
literally ice balls around his hand
after bandaging his severely frostbitten
hands Shakira called 9-1-1 again and
again but the weather conditions made it
impossible for First Responders to reach
them I was waiting for the National
Guards and I still was waiting for 9-1-1
paramedics fired I was waiting for
anybody and nobody ever came
as the hours passed the snow just kept
piling up so Joey spent Christmas with
Shakira Trent and their kids
she did his laundry
fed him even played movies for him we
got to get some help all the while his
hands were literally changing color and
the pain was becoming unbearable I was
thinking
if there's going to take them this long
to come and get him yeah and he's alive
how long is it going to take him to come
and get a dead body if he was the pass I
couldn't wrap my head around I just
couldn't do it this young man's fingers
is going to fall off on Christmas night
she turned to social media panicking I
had to use the ease to cut the ring off
of his finger I'm not no surgeon I'm I'm
right here Joe about 36 hours after
their ordeal began I think these men for
helping two Good Samaritans answered her
plea yeah we all love you we right here
wishing you hear me because what you
tell me I'm your friend right we're
friends right we're friends forever and
when I got in the truck I he told me he
was scared and I said I'm scared too as
I'm scared too Joey and I said you know
we got help we're going to go the
doctors are going to take care of you
and then when he told me he loved me I
knew I knew he really felt safe this man
could have died 64 years old could have
died outside I wasn't letting that
happen on my watch and he wasn't gonna
die in front of my kids what do you
think the takeaway is I feel that
especially nowadays the way our country
is everything is just you know the
weather is terrible this is terrible and
then to see the compassion and the love
with two strangers yeah is is just
amazing so you tell me where the
connection is it's here it's it's it's
not here
we got him to the emergency room in the
spirit of that first Christmas more than
2 000 years ago
Shakira archery made room in her home
and in her heart for that Stranger in me
I'm right here when you think back on it
all
what makes you emotional I know we
needed help
and I just kept thinking about what if
it was my family member
Christmas wasn't even about the gifts
about my kids it wasn't it was literally
him Christmas was him he was a very good
Christmas gift and now for the rest of
my life I will remember him what would
you say to people watching this who will
encounter something down the road
and people should be kind
be loving
we'll take a lesson from you so thank
you you're welcome
oh man I love that I don't even know
what to say yeah listen I I hate to
report this but Joey's sister told me
that doctors had to remove all of his
figures including his knuckles they
weren't able to save them
[Music]
live He's Alive and what Chicago said
I'm here with you I love you we're
friends right we're friends we all felt
that David we all felt that Shakira I
don't even know people of Buffalo
they've been through so much again and
they are amazing when we come back come
and we'll be here at the table be right
back